hello there reject Nation we are going
to watch today the trailer the next
one for John Wick chapter 4 for a Bellum
alrighty guys leave a like it's the morning
and there's Carnage coming our way let's do this
goes out to you Mr Wick what I'm gonna be too
regular wasn't it yeah yeah yeah and
so it begins it's long begun let's go
it's a single combat if you win
you'll have your freedom a duel
ah yes nice sweet
peace
more horses
not really
yeah dogs
oh oh nice what is that action scene he's
using traffic yeah man I've never seen a
fight like that hey they used cars against
him last time he can use cars against them
this time I just love how no one's stopping on
the road no not there you can see my that car
kept going after a body slammed onto the hood
of it isn't that a famous roundabout I feel
like that's one of those places in the world
where they're like yeah you know if you're
slowing down or stopping people just gonna run
you over there's always gun fights and all kinds
of bodies always mean it's locked onto the hood
of my car whenever I go through this roundabout
um yeah this looks awesome a lot of the
way the cinematography is is really sort
of hearkening back more to the first one
in a lot of ways it's got a lot of that
neo-noir lighting to it which looks great and
we are broaching we haven't quite got there yet
um but I think just the thing with the dog the
whole thing with the roundabout it hasn't reached
Fast and Furious level yet where it's like
there's no there's no sense of because they
still they still care about like physics and
this yes obviously brutality but yeah is it is
it getting like really anime levels of identity
yeah I want everybody who's a part of the fight
in the subsequent installments will then just
be part of the team yeah so it's like he's got
his horses he's got his dogs who's next we need a
cat on the team we need like a shark or something
well I mean even there's one porn in the trailer
where he's jumping off what looks like the third
story through a window straight to the street yeah
you know he's gonna be fine yeah he's falling off
the roof of a damn Hotel I I love this thing even
though time to die did it with the car flipping
over or the guys flipping mid air and he's still
shooting they're shooting like two people here
that is insane you gotta slow the this [__]
down damn yeah this is going to be overwhelming
to process in the moment I imagine and I mean
this movie is like two hours and 45 minutes
long so this also kind of is it really yes it is
and it made me think like I mean John Wick movies
obviously belong in the same part of the video
store as like a raid movie but two I'm wondering
if they're gonna go like full Baron doll with this
and just make it like the ultimate like John Wick
movies are certainly operatic in their own way but
I wonder if they're going to go for that full-on
like crime drama epic along with all their fun
crazy John Wick neon stuff that's crazy because
this trailer is only 90 seconds long I know it
hints at almost nothing offer and two I mean
you know you get the brief flashes and stuff like
that but like to have hiroyuki Sonata in here as
well as Donnie Yen and apparently they are going
to fight each other as well as you know dealing
with Johnson with parent doesn't last trailer I
believe yeah so I mean that's gonna be flipping
awesome not a parent from this trailer but that's
gonna be like he's got Scott Atkins in here too
um which uh you know just as exciting as Donnie
I mean not just like Scott Atkins I mean he is
an action movie veteran in his own right now
too brilliant fighter too absolutely is he's
got a great reputation especially among stunt
folks as well which is like this has to be yeah
like the stuff people's dream project now too
is like as much as they bring in characters
from the movies I have to imagine now it's the
goal of just every stunt person ever to beat a
John Wick well the fight here is like the it's
like some kind of Hunger Games level threat of
you know only one man left standing at the
very end of it all but because it's it's a
it's a fight to win in competition but it's
also a fight so he can actually have some
type of Freedom 245 minutes what the hell is the
fifth movie gonna be about what does it matter
there's gonna be a literal high table that's like
this huge metaphysical plane and it all take place
there yeah there's a bunch of philosophical
debates and uh and there are things he said
especially saying right to that it seems like
perhaps the bad guys are gonna get more of a
chance to shine like yeah that one woman who
was climbing that guy stabbing him while they
were going up the staircase and she's like and
then you know you got Donnie Yen in here because
you know I like actors like Mark tacos and um you
know uh common sure yeah I like I like those guys
but you have players in here who are I mean
Common's like really big but you have players
this time around who in the villain category who
you would want to have a lot of screen time in
a film like this you know it seems like they'd
probably have some type of ominous build build
with Bill Skarsgard sure and he's a wonderful
actor so I'm gonna want some like really rich
scenes with this guy and then you got Donnie Yen
who's like an international Superstar so you're
going to want to have some rich scenes with
that guy as well and then you're also having
returning characters like Ian McShane and Lawrence
Fishburne so you're going to want to have great
scenes with them too so you know drawing a Raid
2 parallels actually a really great call because
you know like these trailers obviously hone in
on Keanu the whole time primarily I mean you cut
around to the other people but it's primarily
focusing on Keanu Reeves where you got these
other characters and and some new actors uh in
this franchise we were like yeah I hope they get
a really have a good amount of screen time so
weirdly when you say 2 hours and 45 minutes I'm
not like a great Transformers I'm more like
oh we might get like some actual characters
along with all the crazy barrage of violence and
stuff like that yeah yeah I'm looking forward to
that that sounds really cool that sounds really
cool alrighty guys oh man this is an IMAX yeah
well I know this looks like the kind of movie
that would be perfect to react to but oh it's
Cinema though wait for Creed 3 but watch this
it is it's your IMAX Sophie's Choice which IMAX
experience do I want more I got it I gotta have
one yeah yeah no no it's a cinephile you owe it
to yourself John Wick reaction oh we get way
more fused sure but I I really I'm leaning
more towards that I think I really want to watch
I mean you're a lover of of martial arts and Kung
Fu he's gonna use nunchucks in a way that's not
gonna be stupid like you got to see them on IMAX
that which is called Bruce Lee stupid alrighty
guys since Bruce Lee he's not gonna hit himself in
the nuts for a joke is my point um guys what did
you think about this John Wick chapter 4 trailer
leave your thoughts down below be sure to uh
leave a like subscribe and let's end this with a
David Gandy as gentle of a spirit as you are
I hope that one day you do snap
I hope that everything you love
is taken away from you by someone and then you see
the Dark Side of David Gandhi come out where he
has to go on a Revenge spree because that would be
very short-lived I think that you would probably
be very determined but this would be your first
album like this pretty quick I'm pretty sure you
would jaywalk and you'd get like a ticket and that
might make you reconsider all of your decision
making that you were headed down so David it's
gonna be a great Learning lesson for you once you
realize that revenge is not the path and you will
need financial stability in order to maintain the
things you currently have so maybe wasting your
time on it don't do it just don't do it but you
know make sure that uh you were saying plus your
patreon page that's the way to secure your fealty
and make sure you're being a good human being like
you always are because we love you God loves you
and I love you